today I shall be demonstrating the 13
count Carter for the second level
bukiwozo levels we need the 13
count Carter and the 31 count Carter
this will be the 13 and I will show it
at the pace
that I want it done and um
and then I'll break it down and just
tell you the points that I need to see
clearly
each piece needs to be shown clearly and
accurate
with accuracy
h
knee
sound
she
go
Cheech
Hutch
two
each
to your knee
what's your son
Edge
knee
so
she
go
Cheech
Hutch
who
if you reach
unique
to Sam
photosynthesi said that um
when you're standing in front of him you
must be ready
and I'm telling you the same
a lot of people
have weaknesses that I've noticed their
hands like this
is a weakness
please don't do it when you're ready
you're ready
when you ski don't have the finger
like this
on like this
close them down
when you go into hasso
don't have the hand open at the top
finish it here
then slide it to here
when you do number seven
have the bottom out like this and the
top close
because you're not just protecting
against the ski you're protecting
against a strike for it to blend off
when you come here
this feeling is to strike it away
strike it away
there's two points you can have here you
can have hole there
you go up here
and I
think you can have here
as long as it passes the head you're
safe
don't finish it here this is why you can
practice a layer
or lower they're both okay
but make sure it's past the head
Don't Look Down you should know where
your foot is
and your herbs
they either count before or after is
okay
h
knee
broken down into three places here so
that you see each part correctly knee
so
a lot good block
cheeks
machine break it down into two parts
that one
that's so
make sure the Joe's past the body and
not like this
past the body
settle the body
turn the head first
block
ski
or back come around here arriving it
away
high or low as long as it passes the
head
Edge
me
please son
she
go
Roku
cheats
touchy
rich
to your knee
pitch
knee
sound
she
go
Cheech
Hutch
dude
Jewish
for me
for some
it's
me
[Applause]
so
cute
she
go
cheats
two
rich
ER
Edge
knee
Sun
shine
she
go
go through
chichi
touch
two
true
too rich
your knee
to some
try to
do it cleanly at that place
and with the
forces so that each one looks like a
an individual one so I to a sense he
said 13 Carter has many of the suburi
feelings in them and some servers that
were missing from the 20 Joe Carter so
that's why you don't want to just show
it as a free flow
thank you for your time
don't move myself